bonjour comme beaucoup d'autres j'ai
grandi dans une famille modeste aux rien
été gaspillés du coup dans la famille
tout été recyclés ou conservés au cas où
comme disait ma mère alors ma mère
recycler tout ce qui fait que j'ai passé
la moitié de mon enfance habillée avec
les vêtements de ma soeur alors pas tous
les vêtements parce que les jupes
plissées
j'ai pas vraiment le genre de tour mais
comme ma mère habillé masseur sachant
que j'aurais à remettre ses vêtements
plus tard du coup ma soeur non plus
n'avait pas les vêtements qu'elle aurait
voulu avoir
c'est le charme des familles nombreuses
certains d'entre vous doivent savoir de
quoi je parle
puis les années ont passé j'ai grandi
j'ai connu d'autres formes de mode de
vie car mon environnement aussi avait
beaucoup changé moi qui venais du monde
du on achète si ça casse on répare je
découvrais le monde du en achète si ça
casse on jette et on rachète le monde du
consommable
j'avoue que j'ai eu un peu de mal à
m'habituer tel point qu'à un ami
comédien ma vie sur nommé au cas où
c'est pour dire ce qui est le plus
incroyable c'est que j'ai trouvé une
réelle culpabilité à jeter quelque chose
et aujourd'hui encore je suis
complètement imprégné par cette
éducation et quand je vois à quel point
on emballe est on sûr emballe le moins
de produits alimentaires j'ai toujours
un moment de flottement quand je reviens
des courses et que je fais le rangement
dans le réfrigérateur et je remplis déjà
une poubelle entière d'emballage avant
même d'avoir commencé à manger quoi que
ce soit c'est effrayant quand on y pense
et oui le plastique est omniprésent dans
notre société
certains disent même que nous sommes à
l'âge du plastique
mais c'est aussi parce qu'il a une
action positive sur notre quotidien dans
le transport dans l'isolation dans la
protection sans plastique nous
consommerions beaucoup plus d'énergie
techniquement c'est pas le plastique le
problème le problème c'est la gestion
des déchets qui ne fait jamais partie de
l'équation
quand j'ai commencé à gagner de l'argent
je vais tout de suite utilisée pour
voyager je voulais voir le monde alors
je suis allé un peu partout
mais surtout en afrique puis en asie et
là bas j'ai découvert des paysages
somptueux des images de nature
magnifique mais blessé par des amas de
matière aux couleurs criardes est pas
vraiment naturel c'était triste de voir
ça ou encore ça d'ailleurs qui s'en
réjouir et sûrement pas ceux qui y
vivent
croyez moi ces images sublimes de
liberté et de pureté baisser par la lame
froide de la modernité du consommable
ces pays magnifique sont submergées par
une profusion de plastique qui leur est
impossible de contenir et pourtant ils
en connaissent un rayon sur la technique
du au cas où est beaucoup plus que ma
mère dans ces régions du monde on gâche
pas tout se transforme et serrés et
utilise ces mêmes le royaume du au cas
où
alors pourquoi par quels pouvoirs
étranges les feuilles des arbres se sont
transformés en sacs plastiques et le lit
des rivières en hamac bouteille pour
comprendre un peu mieux ce qui a pu se
passer
je propose de vous donner quelques
chiffres saviez vous que nous produisons
chaque année 275 milliards de kilos de
déchets plastiques
chaque seconde ses seize mille sacs
plastiques qui sont distribués c'est à
dire 500 milliards chaque année qui
finiront dans des centres de tri pour
les villes les plus organisés dans une
décharge pour la grande majorité puis
dans la nature pour les autres et
l'excès quantités vont encore augmenter
dans les prochaines années
alors pourquoi pourquoi un produit si
nécessaire à l'humanité devient-il si
nuisible parce que nous sommes également
à l'âge du consommable et du rendement
ce qui n'est plus utile ce qui ne
rapporte plus est exclu de la société et
pas seulement pour les produits de
consommation
mais notre sac plastique lui va
continuer de vivre sa vie parce qu'il
est coriace plus coriace que nous son
espérance de vie est beaucoup plus
longue que la nôtre 400 ans en moyenne
ça fait rêver non enfin surtout pour
ceux qui ont une belle vie
et comme ne sait pas quoi faire son
existence bailly se promènent cherche
des copains dans les arbres et dans les
rivières où il croise ses cousines les
bouteilles et ensemble ils vont
continuer cette longue migration qui va
les conduire dans les océans
hélas comme des êtres sociaux ils vont
se regrouper dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des gir ou des vortex
c'est leur terre promise à eux les
polypropylène les polyéthylène les
politiques lors sûrs de vinyle les poly
téréphtalate j'ai mis à la fin parce que
c'est plus dur à dire mais tout ça c'est
trop poli pour être honnête il fallait
que je fasse car cette grande famille
des poly et bien les constitué de cinq
mille milliards d'individus en tous
genres et de toutes les tailles
cinq mille milliards imaginez un peu une
galaxie de particules qui attendent
sagement d'être avalé par un poisson ou
une tortue
peut-être même un oiseau si leur taille
le permet et c'est aussi dans notre
assiette qu'elle finisse et particules
disséminés dans la chair des poissons
que nous mangeons ou dans la chair des
animaux qui ont mangé des farines de
poisson avant nous les mange non c'est
devenu un enjeu de santé publique
internationale
il n'existe pas de frontière pour se
protéger nous sommes tous concernés
enfin seulement ceux qui se nourrissent
alors j'ai repensé à cette phrase que
disait ma mère quand j'étais petit au
cas où
au cas où ces déchets auraient une
valeur est ce qu'on les jetterait saviez
vous qu'il n'ya que 20 % des déchets
plastiques qui sont recyclés en france
le reste est brûlée avec un rendement
énergétique moyen des progrès sont faits
mais à ce rythme il faudra encore
attendre trente ou quarante ans avant
d'en avant d'arriver à 100 % de
recyclage
c'est sur cette idée de redonner de la
valeur aux déchets plastiques que j'ai
commencé à réfléchir a cherché à
rencontrer des gens puis j'ai commencé à
trouver des pistes
j'ai lu des articles j'ai vu des
expériences film est un peu partout dans
le monde
en amérique en asie en angleterre aussi
et de toutes ces informations récoltées
se dégager un procédé technique qui
m'intéressait plus que les autres pour
des raisons de logistiques et
économiques retransformer ces déchets
plastiques en quoi et bien en pétrole
oui ce pétrole dont les simples
variations cours influe sur l'économie
mondiale
ce pétrole dont les plus démunis manque
tant du pétrole c'est aussi simple que
ça attention il n'est pas question de
douter des énergies propres
c'est une solution d'urgence dont je
vous parle en attendant les progrès de
la science mais qu'est-ce qui est le
plus souhaitable une plage souillée par
les déchets plastiques ou bien un plein
dans un générateur électrique pour
éclairer tout un village
cette idée de redonner de la valeur au
déchet a commencé à prendre forme
elle s'est concrétisée à travers une
association que j'appelais earth wake
tout d'abord nous avons pensé utiliser
de la haute technologie japonaise
et puis un jour en france j'ai appris
qu'un passionné dans un petit village
des alpes maritimes travaillait dans son
garage sur une drôle de machine
alors on est allé le voir avec toute
l'équipe ii reçoit est qu on était 2
et c'est ingénieurs ingénieux a
effectivement inventé une machine qui
transforme les déchets plastiques en
carburant le procédé est simple mais
très technique il est basé sur la
pyrolyse des matières plastiques
un procédé développé dans les années 70
on porte le plastique à haute
température il devient un gaz que l'on
refroidit pour le ramener à l'état
liquide
voyez c'est simple c'est un peu comme
l'alambic avec lequel on fait le parfum
bon c'est juste l'odeur qui change donc
pour faire simple je vous présente
monsieur et madame carburants qui sont
nés ici en france et qui ont l'air très
très content d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui on est vraiment très content
alors on rigole mais c'est du vrai
carburant qu'on a fait ici avec notre
machine à partir de déchets plastiques
c'est pas de l'huile d'olive
d'ailleurs ça sent pas très bon et vous
pouvez le mettre dans le réservoir de
votre voiture ça marche je le sais parce
qu'on l'a fait mais bon on peut le dire
à personne de ce ca interdit de
l'essence gratuite vous pensez alors
comme ils s'entendent très très bien je
vais leur mettre ensemble en espérant
qu'il nous fasse des petits le buteur ce
wake est de créer un éco système
financier qui profite aux victimes des
pollutions on stimule le ramassage et la
collecte en rachetant de plastique puis
au sein du village
on transforme ce déchet en carburant que
l'on revend pour générer un bénéfice et
racheter encore du déchet plastique et
créer ainsi une économie circulaire
le but est d'aller beaucoup plus loin
que l'environnement en créant des
emplois des compléments de revenus et un
impact positif sur la santé
une espèce de résonance possible entre
écologie et économie où les dividendes
ne sont pas financier mais humain c'est
pour cette raison qu sender souhaité
nous avons pris la décision de
construire une machine non pas en high
tech mais en low tech
pour réduire les coûts et permettent à
ce projet d'être économiquement viable
une machine qui soit robuste et
résistante au climat difficile une
machine facile d'entretien et
transportable sur un camion ou un pick
up mais surtout une machine à taille
humaine qui fasse du bien aux femmes et
aux hommes qui sont victimes de ce fléau
alors qu'ils élèvent leurs enfants dans
l'idée qu'il ne faut pas gaspiller
aujourd'hui l'équipe est en marche il ya
des ingénieurs des chercheurs des
designers qui travaillent avec nous à
perfectionner cette invention des
sponsors qui financent nos premiers pas
les associations qui ont l'expérience du
terrain et beaucoup d'autres encore qui
à leur tour valorise ce projet qui petit
à petit devient réalité
alors maintenant imaginez un monde
on dort et donnerait de la valeur à nos
déchets pour en faire une ressource
imagine un monde où on assainirait des
villages devenus des dépotoirs parce que
ce sont les plus pauvres qui sont les
plus touchés imaginez un monde où l'on
lutterait contre des maladies comme le
paludisme
oui véhiculée par les moustiques qui
trouvent dans les eaux sales qui sont
retenues par les déchets plastiques des
lieux de reproduction idéaux mais
surtout imaginer un monde on
débarrasserait les océans de ces
milliards de déchets plastiques
simplement parce que l'être humain est
ainsi fait qu'il ne laisse jamais
traîner quelque chose qui a de la valeur
merci de m'avoir écouté
et surtout merci à ma maman que je
cherche un peu mais que j'aime tant et
merci à toutes les mamans du monde qui
prennent le temps d'enseigner à leurs
enfants qu'il ne faut pas gaspiller
excusez moi je fais beaucoup de faim une
dernière chose depuis que nous parlons
8000 tonnes de plastique ont été
empêchés bien sûr ont été produits sur
notre planète
et encore j'ai parlé vite ans alors
voilà le problème est posé
einstein a dit les personnes qui n'ont
jamais commis d'erreur sont des
personnes qui n'ont jamais tenté
d'innover
alors je prends le risque parce que je
suis persuadé que notre solution peut
fonctionner et j'aimerais vraiment
vraiment beaucoup qu'on l'attend
ensemble au cas où